kahlan response thank you all for coming
now I can't see any of you thank you all
for coming to tonight's performance and
QA before we start a couple of very
brief announcements first we want to
thank that de Flores fund for humor for
helping us put this on if you have any
funny ideas please apply to the de
Flores fund we can approve grants of
seven hundred and fifty dollars at any
time and grants more than that twice a
year
there is a mailing list for the
communications forum which this is a
part of right outside there on a table
if you sign up for that we will only
send you emails about events so you'll
get between five and six emails a year
but if you want to be kept informed
about things like this please do that
and there are also materials from the
title nine of violence prevention and
response office on the table outside
tonight we are all here to see Cameron
Esposito who is a nationally headlining
comedian she has appeared in feature
films on Comedy Central on HBO she's to
write a column for The AV Club she has
she's been a part of several incredible
podcasts her most recent comedy special
is one that I cannot recommend highly
enough it's called rape jokes and it
deals with sexual assault from a
survivors perspective and it has so that
so far raised more than ninety five
thousand dollars for the rape abuse and
incest national network it is available
for streaming on her website Cameron
Esposito dot-com
before we call her out a couple of very
quick guidelines for tonight you are
welcome to take pictures as long as
there are no flash please do not make
any video recordings but pictures are
fine and please no audio recordings
after Cameron does first and upset we're
going to do a brief Q&A and then an
audience Q&A so don't leave when she is
done and with that will you please join
me in giving a big welcome to Cameron
Esposito
[Applause]
so now I'm gonna do a stand-up set 45
minutes or so a couple of other quick
announcements before we go on in my
excitement to get Cameron out here I
neglected to thank two other places at
MIT that helped us put this on the mind
hand heart Innovation Fund and Women and
Gender Studies at MIT
both of whom did a lot to help make this
happen so the way this is going to work
Cameron and I are gonna talk for a
little while will open it up to you we
have two microphones so during the Q&A
part you can come down and stand at the
mic if you are unable to come down to
the mic for some reason just raise your
hand and we will get a mic to you also
before we start this portion it's
possible that during this section of the
night we're gonna talk about a topic
that might bring up something in some of
you and we want to know that you do have
support violence prevention and response
is mi t--'s confidential resource for
sexual assault stalking harassment and
sexual harassment and what confidential
means in this context there are
university employees typically are
required to report sexual harassment or
sexual assault under title 9 laws
violence prevention and response is a
place where you can go and talk to them
confidentially they do not give your
name to anyone there's not a report that
needs to come out of that that is up to
you they have a 24 hour hotline and
there's also an advocate here Alessandra
who can offer support the hotline number
is six one seven two five three 2,300
again there's a valve wrench and
response table right outside along with
the communications forum sign-up sheet
which we hope you sign up for so I'll
move over here surf that actually like
get down I was gonna sit down on the
ground this is so satisfying I mean I
might take this out but it's just so
cute this is like a table guy yeah
exactly
right just sit on the floor like that
sweetest thing I ever saw yeah no I know
I know I know
yes I know but it's just this personal
this fun it's the world's most
ineffective boom mic you're you're in
the shot no I know it's I just only have
so much so thank you for coming oh yes
we're quiz you on the different course
numbers later that was a fun part of the
show I still don't have no idea what
they are and I've been here for nine
years I think so people say like I'm in
course three and I just not there you go
somebody who's really a fan of course
three so well I wanted to ask first
about about your special yeah
rape jokes what made you what brought
that about what made you want to do that
and we haven't talked at all about it I
know if you want to talk a little bit
about what that special is yeah
absolutely so it's um it's an hour about
sexual assault from my first-person
perspective as a survivor and um I put
it out for free on my website and I know
you mentioned this in my intro but I'll
just say this all to you because you
know I know these are times where you
can it just can feel so overwhelming
like is there even anything good in the
world sometimes in
so you can watch it for free and then
there's an option where you can choose
to donate and so folks have chosen to
donate over ninety five thousand dollars
like it's a for free thing so that to me
it gives me a lot of Hope and really
love that so just shout out to all of
the human beings that are the felt
affected enough and I got a chance to go
to a rain is the world the nation's
largest anti-sexual violence
organization I got a chance to join
their organization on their Advisory
Council and to go to see the room where
they take phone calls and so this has
been a really wonderful process for me
in the process of making that special
was I woke up in the middle of the night
and I just like had that title in my
head because rape jokes are it's like
been it's one of those things that's
been debated for as long as I've been
doing comedy like are there are certain
topics that are off-limits and it's like
it's it just strikes me as utter
silliness because when people are
talking about something like sexual
assault first of all there always seems
to be this implied difference but that
men and women feel differently about
sexual assault and I find that in my
anecdotal evidence it's experience that
is not true
like I know a lot of men who either are
survivors themselves or who like came up
to me and told me how much this affected
them so like I kind of think a lot of us
are on the same side which is the side
of justice that's the first thing and
good communication and better education
because one of our biggest problems I
think as a country is that we don't have
sex ads so how can you know when whether
or not you're doing something consensual
but but uh the other thing I hear often
when I hear people talk about rape jokes
is like they'll be just a comic will go
out and say something that's just
deliberately offensive or obtuse in some
way and then get upset that the audience
wants more from them as a comic like
don't be a fennec buck up in censorship
and it's sort of the stuff I was talking
about
during my set and I I just think like if
you're a comic and somebody tells you
hey be more careful with this thing that
has really affected real people that you
should want to be a good enough artist
to make better jokes like that somebody
giving you feedback is an opportunity to
improve your art especially I also
always assume there are survivors in the
room because I'm a survivor
so we all it's also something that we
talk about as if like there's nobody
affected by it it's one of those topics
that we just trot out to talk about as
if it only affects people outside the
room and statistically it affects people
in every single room that we're in so I
just think there's a huge shift that we
could make him I was happy with the with
rape jokes for just doing a tiny bit too
well at least to get my opinion out
there and then when you do donate it's
very cool cuz like two seconds later you
get an email from Cameron that says
thank you and I was like oh my god
you're so welcome
I imagined you every individual time
thank you so much Seth manukan and so so
what is the experience of then of taking
that out and and and talking to people
after that show and after you do do do
that stand-up what does that experience
been like with audiences well I only I
only did that material in really small
rooms because I didn't feel like it was
something more I could come out in like
a like when I'm here in Boston I often
play the Wilburn like that's a big
beautiful room but I didn't feel like I
could go into the wilber and like bring
up this topic and then just sort of like
leave so I'd only did it in rooms that
were a hundred max people and sometimes
smaller than that because I wanted to
like have a chance to be with the
audience afterwards because a lot of
times people would out themselves to me
as survivors or that they had survivors
and their family or just have a chance
to like connect on it and it just felt
to me like I didn't feel like it was
something I could come out and dump on
an audience even though it's like
it's not like a heavy special it's real
and there are parts that aren't funny
but it's it's not like to do damage but
I just felt like there was some
aftercare required right yeah so it was
like really intimate audiences and I and
I heard directly from a lot of people
it's not usually my experience I play
bigger rooms than that now and so
sometimes there's like a really big line
and I'm not trying to sound arrogant but
it's just too much bigger yeah I play
bigger rooms now so there's like a much
bigger line so it just it's not as easy
to be with individual people because
there's like a bunch of people behind so
you like try to keep it moving yeah but
that didn't feel like what I could do
for this and and is that so now that
you've done that special do you think
you will continue to do that in smaller
rooms are you moving on to other yeah I
will never do that
material again I don't think it was in
here but like as the our that exists
like I don't think I'll ever do it again
um I was so lucky to get a chance to
this was like the coolest project cuz
also people donated their time which is
something I never asked folks to to
donate for things that they should be
paid for but in this case I knew that
all the money was gonna be donated and I
knew I was donating my time so I felt a
little more comfortable and I just feel
like I captured exactly what I wanted to
capture and I think it's like I'm very
proud of it and it exists and I feel
like now I can move on but I gotta say
my piece and that's more than most
people get to do yeah
[Applause]
moving back a bit you obviously were not
you didn't major in comedy in college
was what got you into improv it sounds
like pretty much right after school you
started getting involved in improv yeah
well actually at BC has the weirdly has
the oldest collegiate improv group in
the country it's called my mother's
fleabag it still exists um Amy Poehler
wasn't it ten years before I was and so
when I was at school amy was like just
breaking out on SNL so there was this
feeling like oh all you do is just like
act like a banana in the cafeteria for
like three nights a month or whatever
and then like you get to be a famous
person you know um and I got my first
job working professionally in improv the
day after I graduated
so it's I've always since the day after
I graduated from school I've been
working professionally in comedy and did
you always know you wanted to perform
and it sounds like you were it was just
a red-winged you know that bird yes no I
was I was a jock I've played a lot of
sports yeah yeah like I was like a
three-sport athlete in high school and
um and I was like on student council and
stuff like that I was like very involved
the person setting up for the dances and
if you can if you remember that person
like the person's like putting streamers
everywhere all the time and then it BC I
played rugby what yeah is Adelaide rugby
woo yeah yeah I played rugby so yeah I I
didn't know about well that's why I
asked some of you like like what you're
studying because I really didn't know
this was a job I went to like a college
prep high school and I really didn't
know anybody that wasn't Catholic and I
I didn't know that arts and
entertainment like I would see people on
TV and I did
understand I think maybe I still had
like almost like an infant's
understanding of like they live in the
in the TV like I just you know like I
like it's crowded and they have to share
a bed there's a lot of them yeah I
didn't know this was a job so I even
didn't know what is a job after I was
doing it professionally like I I applied
to go to grad school and I started
getting my Masters in Social Work I when
I worked when I lived out here I worked
in special ed with kids with severe
physical special needs and so I was
still I was doing comedy at night I had
other stuff that I thought would be my
career I thought comedy would be my
passion you could have been an uplift
driver that's right I could have been
too true and and you're a comedian
obviously this is true of most stand-ups
who talks a lot about your own life
shares very intimate things we now live
in a culture where the audience the
world at large feels like they have a
right to interact with anyone who's
famous in any way in any manner what is
that experience like I would guess that
you're dealing with difficult subjects
that not all of the comments you get are
fully supportive oh yeah that's a good
question well I have a new approach to
social media these days we're like I
really am NOT ever on anything so I
don't see as I don't see as much as many
comments even like the positive comments
to I don't really see as much as I used
to
during the first maybe say 10 years of
my career it was I pretty much only got
discouragement if that makes any sense
you know like people that I worked with
other comics sometimes work
to me or like there were a lot of
improvisers here in Boston who made me
think I could do this job but I don't
know if this is gonna like shock any of
you we were talking about this backstage
I am like truly the first part of the
first generation of comics that could
start out you know Ellen was well into
her career and with her own television
show when she came out in the 90s and
then was blacklisted and had to like
literally go away for a while before she
reached as a fish and this is all real
and like take Notaro who's maybe in the
like it may be one generation ahead of
me you know was it a wasn't maybe clique
not closeted but like not not like
didn't start talking about her life her
personal life um and I'm just naming
those people that's true of like
everybody in that generation you know
like a lot of well not everybody there
were some people that were out like Lea
delaria who's who's like now on orange
is the new black what has been out
forever but she got oranges the new
black and she's 60 you know like she got
that job five years ago or whatever that
is you know so you know that's how long
it took for somebody who started out to
have mainstream success and I'm really
part of the first generation that like
got to be out the whole time so yeah for
ten years that was really really
difficult for people like I basically
just got told to shut up we're like talk
about something else why do you have to
talk about being gay talk about
something else I'm like well do you want
me to talk about being straight like I
don't and also I mean straight male
comedians never talk about their sex
life so that's true it's honestly what
do they have sex I don't know
how does it look when they jerk off I
don't know I've never seen it you know
um you know so it was weird right yeah
and so now 10 years into your career is
that do you see that being sort of the
same for men and women in in the LGBTQI
community or is it is there something
different yeah that's a good question
well actually just to give like oh do
you speak for all gay man yeah yeah well
well just to give like more accurate
information
I'm actually like 15 years in now so I'm
not saying that - what I mean is the
first 10 we're really hard then the last
five have been really interesting where
I've been getting like rewarded right uh
for being an unusual voice and I'm like
wait what like I almost don't trust it I
will say it it is it is true that there
has never been an out gay male mega star
in the stand-up world there also hasn't
really been a mega star that's like
trans person or a non-binary person if
you think about it that that's like wow
that's true and um I think some of that
is who has been cultured to like take up
space you know I think a lot of times
like it's just a numbers game that oh
wow I guess I'll get into like - gender
theory or whatever but like like there
are a lot of lesbians who do stand-up
because we don't care what men think of
us and it's very difficult to be a woman
will we do I mean I still do of course
I'm cultured female of course I care
about and think about me except me they
think I'm beautiful like I don't even I
don't want you at all but could you like
please validate me it's very confusing
um but I think if you're a straight
woman you know I can't like really get
into this laughter is a submissive
behavior I don't know if we if we know
this but like I don't know I read this
I've read like studies and like books on
it it's a submissive the person that's
on stage is like the leader they're
dominating you and that
and that can feel really good like it
actually can feel really nice to be like
held in that way but I think sometimes
for men if that's a woman
she's a straight woman she's then gonna
have like her life is gonna be hard she
have a difficult time dating she didn't
have a difficult time figuring out how
to find a partner because her partner is
culture to be threatened by her and I
think that same thing kind of then
extends to gay men where it's like
homophobia against gay men is actually
really misogyny because we hate the idea
that like being penetrated is like the
worst thing that can happen to you and
we think about gay men as a society we
think about like the sex act that gay
men do that also like a ton of straight
people do but for some reason is like
really gay it's confusing women also
have buttholes there's a lot you know
but I think that when you know I bring
up all that that all sounds like very
tangential stuff but like you know
stand-up is like everything else where
that all the same gender dynamics play
out and um I really I can't wait to see
who the first like gay male megastar is
maybe jus Buki what young wait he's he's
on The Daily Show now or maybe Joel can
boost her um but yeah that'll happen
someday there was one thing that you
said in there special that I loved and I
hope I wrote down and I probably didn't
I did not or I took the wrong piece of
paper but it was something you were
talking about basketball shorts guy yeah
and which is like a character in the
special basketball shorts guy who
actually nailed it yeah and but and you
said something like it was like you know
stand up get in the way get in the way
yeah see I didn't even need to write it
down yeah I know my you could ask me
yeah I'll tell you
and and I thought that was that was
really interesting because you know
people will come to me because I
professor for whatever reason to look
for me for advice don't say well what
can I do I feel helpless in this
situation this geopolitical situation
what can I do and I thought that was
really interesting without asking you to
get into the whole thing
what does that mean like what is that
what was he embodying there yeah oh
maybe like get a little bit specific
with the story then I'll tell you a
little bit about how I've applied it in
other ways and then this would be like
not to do your job but I bet this would
be like a really good lead-in because
for for other questions because I feel
like we go at confab and then yeah yeah
no I just I feel like this is gonna be
there's gonna be some like cool
questions maybe they come from this so
this moment that you're talking about is
you know I was an undergrad when I was
assaulted and it was a friend and that
person later approached me and was very
aggressive with me and it was another
student dude who like stepped between us
and he like it was a I literally don't
even remember this guy's name like that
is how indelible he as an individual was
in my life that's how close friends we
were not really close friends the person
who stepped between but still like in
passing this person has like changed my
life and I think about how like he could
absolutely have chosen to just walk by
and let the scene play out and instead
he stepped between and that is something
that I'm so grateful for you know in
that situation and it's also what I'm
trying to do in the world with my career
when I make a special make it available
for free I'm where you don't have to
sign up for a service a streaming
service or pay for a subscription or for
cable or whatever trying to like
interrupt this system that we live in or
I had a television show for awhile this
called take my wife and
um a very low-budget television show and
we made a decision to go for these
really specific numbers in terms of
diversity like an all-female writers
room that was also 40% people women of
color and that also our cast was over
50% out LGBT actors and when our show
was cancelled because our streaming
service was just like was went defunct
our show wasn't really cancelled but we
were able to release these numbers and
we have these you know this is a show
that operated it like the 10th of a
budget that a show on HBO would be at or
like a 20th of a show on network
television and we had these numbers
these diversity numbers that that it
like trended on Twitter and a lot of
media outlets picked up these numbers
and because like we deliberately
designed it so that it's like well we
have like no money and money is time so
we're making this show faster than
you're making your show but we just went
in with a mandate and this is what we
were able to do and being able to
release those numbers felt again to me
it's like these little moments to
disrupt the system like put a challenge
out to other people who are in a
position to hire folks like here's what
I was able to do you know improve on
this and yeah so that's what I've tried
to do in my career thus far and I think
that's hopefully what I'll continue to
get to do full
and after the streaming service shut
down then it was picked up right yes
stars bought the show so stars is you
can watch her on stars yeah another
thing that was really fascinating about
about your special about getting it
online is that you don't you don't even
need to sign up for a newsletter you can
you go on and and watch it yeah you can
just press play that's all you have to
do yeah it's worth doing why don't we
open it up to the audience and again
come down to either one of the mice it
doesn't seem like a super shy crowd but
oftentimes it takes one person to to get
things started while we're waiting for
that are you working special yeah I'm
about to go well I was working on a new
hour this fall but I also just turned in
the second draft of a book Wow
I'm out trying to sell a new TV show
right now we'll see what happens there
but um I'm gonna lay a lot and then I'm
gonna go back out on the road and I'm
gonna work on the next hour of material
but yeah you know I don't know still
plays a question oh yeah cool you know
you got do you enjoy being on the road
oh it is so lonely it is so lonely
it's so lonely being on the road it's
also so nice I love my job but sometimes
I wish I could go home and see my dog
he's sweetie hi so I am an engineer but
I also am a poet and I am starting to
perform my poetry and I was wondering
because I saw rape jokes and I really
liked it and meant a lot to me how do
you as a performer walk the line of
trying to talk about really difficult
experiences and trying to talk about
stuff that isn't talked about enough but
also keeping in mind the fact that there
is an audience that might be affected
and might have feels to your feels sure
you mean like what do I do about the
fact that there might be that a survivor
well yeah like what is what is your
perspective on like trying to navigate
that space yeah I mean I just feel like
um I try to be pretty conscientious as
conscientious as I can be but that being
said like I am just one person and one
thing that I think helps a lot is to
make sure that you're investigating your
own experience and really speaking only
for yourself because that's why I felt
like I could do a special like rape
jokes because I felt like well I'm not
trying to speak about rape culture I'm
trying to speak about my experience and
the more specific and the more personal
I am the more that speaks about rape
culture so I just I find that like you
know that is how we do the best work is
when we just try to speak only for
ourselves
um does that make sense yeah no it does
yeah thank you yeah that's such a good
question first quick thing is I when did
you know our our class numbers also our
classes are also by numbers not just our
courses so I thought everything
some here but I want to say is like I
don't know every gay person you know out
there like journey of like figuring out
they're gay and whatnot and for me
there's like a huge like time in my life
when I didn't realize I could be gay and
then I watched BuzzFeed's ask a lesbian
featuring you you're welcome
you're welcome I could be gay / like
definitely was that's sort of like my
turning point am I like I don't know in
my life a little bit me like in the
hallway watching this video and so like
you mean a lot to me and I was wondering
if you possibly get an autograph either
now or after the show
good
that's so cool that's the that's the
whole goal is yes yes no goal is uh I
really I don't I'm not saying it's too
like to be overly sad or anything but I
really didn't have anybody you know I
really have tried to be the person I
didn't have like for my own little baby
self like I used to when I was at PCC my
girlfriend and I we used to take the
train to Davis Square to go to the
diesel cafe where there's just like
haircuts and I don't know if you are I
don't know if you that is in a two hour
tea journey like that is like those
could not be further apart we would just
go there I don't even think we I don't
even think we ever ordered we would just
walk in and go like and then like leave
you know so I really think it matters to
see you know to see what you could
possibly be so thank you for telling me
that
yeah the answer is is dreamcatcher yes
as dreamcatchers we lay them on the
windowsill to dry you make a
dreamcatcher i slide to my own joke yes
so I am the adopted daughter of lesbians
and I really love your show myself and
I'm and I really loved the scene where
you discuss adoption and I'm wondering
if you could sort of elaborate on this
story behind creating that oh wow oh
thank you so first of all yeah thank you
for you came here from Wellesley yes
thank you so much for making that trip
with so excited that's so rad yeah
thank you yeah oh my god that [ __ ] I
like I'm having a complete blackout on
specifically what the dialog is only
because I've done so much performing
census you haven't memorized every
single thing you've ever done yeah yeah
but um what what is true about that [ __ ]
about take my wife is that I made it
with my wife Rhea butcher and it was the
coolest experience making that show
because what we got to do was talk about
things that are real for queer folks and
then to a room of people and some of our
writers were queer and then some our
writers were not queer and so we would
write these scripts that included like
you know talking about like how
expensive adoption is or like how you
don't know what you're gonna do with
your eggs you're like how are you gonna
get kids you can buyer steal I'm like
what are you gonna do and you know we
would write these jokes and then here's
the other thing that we did that like
I'm actually so proud of is we we hired
additional queer folks to come in and
did a table read like for just queer
people to be like is there anything in
here that doesn't ring like as true as
it could be for like our community or
how much where could we get more
specific and stuff like that so it's
literally like two queer show runners
and then with some queer writers and
then doing like we did literally be
called a gay pass like just do an
additional you know pass on top of that
and then also tried to hire out LGBT
actors that the things that were coming
out of our mouths were things that we
had lived experience with and I just I
look at you know what other I'm not
trying to pass judgment but I look at
like like there are some really great
movies but so often when characters pop
up in shows it's like a random room of
straight writers trying to address a
topic
and then that's when you get like weird
like jokes about closets and you're like
that what you know like you don't I mean
it's like so I think on everything in
that in that show it was like just
trying to make something that felt
really honest yeah Wow oh my god well
tell your folks I say hi I'm so thank
you so much for telling me your life
yeah hello friend hi my name's Sam
really really happy to be here thank you
so much for coming and thank you for
championing the message that diversity
is part of what makes this country good
it's really important I enjoyed hearing
the snippet of story about basketball
shorts student um and how he was able to
step in and be an ally I'm part of the
business school allies group for men who
are trying to like what that's amazing
that that even exists thank you your
business school allies group like we are
literally there that it's that specific
[ __ ] awesome all right yeah keep
going yes I mean we accept all our highs
but yes I love this um my question is
basically about how to encourage more
people to be allies not just how can I
be better which I would also appreciate
your your advice but how do how to get
more people to recognize the need and
understand how they can take action this
is a good question and I I would say for
me the only solution that has ever
worked um is telling and it's like not
unlike this the answer that I gave to
you it's like is um telling people why
something matters to me like I just I
really feel like we're we're in this
moment where it feels like we should
like the inclination is often to like
address a massive social issue sure
but I find that that can turn people off
you know or even overwhelm people it's
literally why I think stand up as a
valuable art because you're on your
you're on stage talking about like
here's my experience here's my
experience and you're not saying you're
not it's not like constructive it's not
like here's what you should do so I mean
I would say something that like if I
were in your shoes I could imagine like
you're you know hanging out with some
buddies or whatever and you just talk
about this thing that you're doing and
why it's important to you and like let
them decide whether or not they want to
come in your direction but I just I
think often you know attraction works
better than like even evangelization
Deaver I'm saying I think that like just
talking about what you already do here
in this room now people know that's a
thing that exists or whatever and like I
think that's I think that's one way to
do it cool yeah thank yeah absolutely
yes yeah cool I don't know yeah yeah go
go go
but I wanted to know I know
I feel wow first of all like that way to
know yourself oh yeah I guess so again
this is when his moments where it's
slightly weird to yell good good good I
don't remember what I was going to say
but stuff I think it would be really
great if you could have a little bit of
a uplift session especially considering
no pressure
but hearing your stand up for like I
don't know the past like 17,000 years
I've I've been listening to you like for
forever Oh
and actually because of my older sister
who is also gay sorry parents
you're welcome parents you're like
weren't like Tegan and Sara but we're
not the same age no no we could become a
lucrative band but but like growing up
Catholic and like you know my high
school experience from your standup has
seems very similar to yours
so no pressure but your advice means a
lot to me already even though you
haven't given it to me and I recently
just stood up in front of a crowd and
talked about - it's two instances of
sexual assault that happened to me um it
took me a lot of like accept it because
it was a girl and I was like uh I
probably just didn't say no loud enough
cuz it wasn't a dude who was forcing
himself on me and so I recently just
like stood up in front of a crowd and
talked about it which was really
powerful and I'm also currently taking a
political class at Harvard which is
interesting and so right now I'm Matt
I'm a senior I'm senior spring and I'm
graduating and I'm like what the [ __ ] am
I gonna do with my life right and
thinking about that experience I had
that was super powerful talking about
like not only LGBTQ stuff but also
sexual assault I'm in front of a crowd
of people I'm like do I you know go into
politics and change laws do I do
stand-up comedy because that's also kind
of a secret area of mine and like talk
about it through humor because like
that's how I you know talk about my
feelings through humor and or do I like
just join a bunch of organizations like
Fenway health and things like that um
and just like how do i how do I make a
difference how do I make an impact or is
it just like that's that's where I'm at
well first of all I'm so sorry that that
happened to you thank you for thank you
for telling me and um it's a second of
all I want to say that um I think you're
at an age where maybe you don't need to
have the answer to that question and
that investigation and information is so
helpful you know I I remember how
overwhelmed I felt at this time and like
it's not like now in my life I never
feel I've certainly have decisions again
where I'm like is this the right thing
to do next and sometimes in my mind I
can get I can worry about is this the
right thing will this be the right thing
to do in ten years or something like
that
and that's very hard to know the thing
that you can know is like what's the
first step that you can take so like the
first step that you could take if you
were gonna be a stand-up is to go to an
open mic and sign up and go on stage and
the first step that you could take if
you want to be a politician is like
probably to take the LSAT you know like
and you know and the first step for
joining those organizations is maybe to
join one of them and go to a meeting and
see how that feels so I I would just say
like I know if there's all this pressure
and it feels like you have to know the
answer but like I said I did I mean I
didn't start doing stand-up full-time or
comedy full-time as my job until I was
like 27 so you know 22 to 27 five years
and sometimes people sometimes it takes
people you know much much longer than
that or whatever but you know I spent
five years doing multiple things to
figure out what was the right thing for
me and that's okay too so I just would
say the advice is to take the the first
step see if you like it then take the
step the second step and not worry about
changing the world but worry about what
you like I was incredible is my first
step giving you 5/5 stars
yes
sit five stars five stars yes yeah thank
you
oh this person oh I'm so sorry
everybody's killing it thank you very
much for being here tonight I've also
listened listened a lot to you like
special medic at the beginning of my
college years I'm a senior now and it
did mean a lot to me and I specifically
have a question for you because at some
point in your life you've been very
Catholic and now you're very gay I love
it I love it the same is true for me
except that I grew up in very Catholic
Italy and for some reason it never
occurred to me that there was something
wrong with like being Catholic and being
gay just because I didn't feel quite as
much homophobia in Italy even though I
used to go to church I get wither and
like everything and then when I came to
the US as a college freshman this first
moment in which I realized oh wait there
are people who have problems with me
being like gay and Catholic at the same
time and well that is a it's a larger
discourse I guess it's like more of a
personal journey but what felt really
confusing to me about the u.s. is that I
felt in a way rejected by the Catholic
community and I met at MIT because I
looked gay I had an undercut and
[Laughter]
I guess but they also found that
sometimes interacting with like
presenting myself as gay was like I
don't know weird for people who knew I
was Catholic so I just wanted to know
what your take on that is yeah thank you
for our since that question um you know
I think my journey on it has been it's
not it's not actually a queerness that I
think conflicts well no it is that too
but um I just I grew up thinking that
that that the church was about community
and Trust and doing the right thing in
the world and I'm now at the point of my
life where like I'm still for I will
always consider myself like ethnically
Catholic because I I really was raised
in this specific way I can't like undo
it in my brain um but it was it was like
in in college the thing that first made
me push away from the church was
actually not coming out it was when I
like was that the algae meter I read all
of the stuff and I read what the church
thought about women and I read like
about being a vessel and why I couldn't
be a priest and it made me so sad you
know like we are more than 50% of the
world's population and the Catholic
Church is one of the wealthiest
organizations in the world they own
they're like the third biggest landowner
they oh it's like it's like the Queen of
England the king of Saudi Arabia and the
church and there's so much money and so
much opportunity to do good work and
instead like the more I investigated I
was like oh we went to like my faith
went to Mexico and built churches on you
know indigenous
land or took space that had been
occupied by somebody else and killed the
people in there and put a cross on it
and I I then and then I was at BC when
the sex abuse scandal happened here in
Boston and um right after I graduated it
was saying backstage that like BC bought
a parcel of land from the archdiocese
that is butting up against the
university and that money from that was
then given to survivors of sex abuse
they openly did this like it wasn't even
like a weird backdoor deal it was like B
C's said like we are buying this land
from the church and the archdiocese said
like we are going to give to survivors
so my college tuition went to offset
abuse and I just I I don't know that I
think that anybody has to make any
particular decision about like whether
you believe in certain things or whether
you go to Mass I'm just somebody who
thinks that we have to look at things
conscientiously and like this
organization that I was born into I feel
an enormous responsibility to be honest
about in the public realm like just
because we have good football teams
doesn't mean we're good people
so that's kind of my take on it is that
I just think it's like you know if it
feels helpful to you and it feels
beautiful to you and it feels like you
can do good work from that like cool I
just also want that to come with honesty
about what that organization really is
and really does yeah sounds like we're
on the same page yeah we actually are
thank you but you said it's so beautiful
and so concisely thank you absolutely
yeah
[Applause]
thank you again Cameron I so want the
day to happen when your niece says are
you pooping and someone says yes I am
pooping I want that for her too I know
she kept waiting for just someone to be
pooping right none of you are
let me ask again great follow-up
question she was not pooping that is
what we all assumed that's how she was
covering for it are are you pooping I'm
not but no she wasn't
I don't that would also be great if she
was pooping and she wanted to just like
no it's late Bella's not my dad that 40
year old man well thank you again so
much for for coming again I'd like to
thank women and gender studies my pen
heart the de Flores bond and violence
prevention and response thank all of you
for being here again violence prevention
response will be outside our sign up is
outside and we hope we see you all in
the future thank you
[Applause]